- First of all, the level of talent
in this film is insane.
- Oh, the cast?
- It's Diane Keaton,
it's Susan Sarandon.
- Susan Sarandon.
- William H. Macy, Richard
Gere, and it's everybody.
Oh, and I love that you're doing a movie
with Luke as well, 'cause
y'all did "Holiday."
- Luke Bracey, yeah, so...
- Can y'all do the Meg
Ryan, Tom Hanks thing
and just do movies together?
- I know, I love him.
- I love y'all.
- We have the, thank you.
We have the best time together.
No, when I...
- You have the best chemistry.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- When I read this script,
and they were like,
Diane Keaton's doing it.
Susan Sarandon's doing it.
Richard Gere's doing it.
William H. Macy.
I'm like, did you guys mean to call me?
Is this, I was like, wait,
you want me to be in this?
And then actually, Luke was
one of the last people cast,
'cause they're like, who
should be your counterpart?
And I'm like, it has to be Luke.
- Oh my God.
- And I texted him.
I was like, "If you say no,
I am coming to find you."
- And punch you.
- And he was like, "No, I won't, I won't."
I was like, "I will be pissed,"
because there've been a couple
other movies that I'm like,
do this with me.
And he we're both like not
quite right, not quite right.
And this, I was like, if
you say not quite right
to Diane Keaton and Susan Sarandon,
I'm done with you.
- Then you're wrong.
Yeah, no I just love
when actors do that too.
I think fans, we all
love that, watching...
- I love it.
I always, I'm like always wanna see people
that have done movies together reunited.
- I know.
- It's comforting.
I was, I turned on and I
was like, this is "Holiday."
I was like, wait, this is the
same, and I love "Holiday."
- Thank you.
- Way to go,
because not few,
and I remember I said
this last time, I think,
but there are very few movies
that come out on Christmas Day
that I feel like really nail it
that you wanna watch every year.
- Thank you.
- And that is a good one.
- But anyway...